[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream numbers at 153. it
is number
153. there was some contention about
that last how you count live streams yes
but it is the officially numbered 150
grudgingly you grudgingly seated which I
appreciate
um but in any case it's the one we're
calling 153. here we are it's
mid-December here we are we got two more
that we're gonna do before the end of
the year actually
um we're not going to come to you on
Christmas Eve though next week will be
coming a day early on the 23rd of
December on Friday the 23rd and then
we're going to be here on New Year's Eve
but actually with you guys this is our
last live stream before the solstice yes
indeed which means that the next time we
see you winter will no longer be coming
it will be here and we will be enduring
no doubt yes I hope so yes well I'm
assuming yes
um all right much much has happened but
we will start with uh we'll start with
the usual spiels and Logistics but first
let's just give an indication of of
where we're going uh we're going to talk
a bit about the shadow CDC
and um
and how many people have been saved by
the covert vaccines
and our Lord and savior Tony fauci
and the White House Summit on equity and
inclusion in stem with two M's the
second M is for medicine
so that's science technology engineering
math and medicine and of course we're
going to talk about snake genitalia of
course yep it's you know it's
traditional now I said that I indicated
that in the tweet that I put out in
advance of today's show and I do think
that some people thought I was joking
but now I am not
no they don't it's a weird subject and I
don't know what's coming but no you
don't no but no I thought I'd keep it
from you I'm ready yes I know you are
yeah always
ah apparently our heating system thinks
that Winter's already here and it's just
kicked into gear
that's amazing yeah so apologies if if
y'all can hear that thermostats what
will they think of next yeah well it's
better that than uh
it's it's better that than us freezing
here all right we have we're going to
follow today uh where the live q a as we
usually do uh you can ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com
uh if you are still looking for holiday
gifts so we did a special holiday gift
episode
some time ago I don't even remember Lots
happened I was in Mexico Brett was in
Florida
um
but we did a gift episode where we
recommend some things including we
recommend that episode but including
hunter-gatherer's guide to 21st century
which is now available in several
languages besides English although we
can only vouch for the English one uh if
you're watching on YouTube you can
switch to Odyssey uh chat is live on
Odyssey you can find things that I write
on natural selection since we saw you
last I'm not going to be talking about
today but I alluded to something that
I'd be announcing in my sub stack
natural
selections.substack.com the last time we
were live and I have tendered my
resignation from the Board of Trustees
at the University of Austin and I posted
my resignation letter along with some
additional uh background although not
enough to appease many people
um at substech at Natural Selections and
I also wrote this week about the value
of Dawn and dusk experienced in Mexico I
was in La Paz in Baja and there is a
waterfront Boardwalk that is very
popular and it is extremely well lit and
at least in the Christmas season it is
even more than usually well it and it
takes away the possibility for the slow
fading or the slow growing of light that
we of course evolved with and that
allows us to readjust our senses and
rely slowly on other senses as the light
is fading before our eyes sort of tune
in and it really really is a loss and so
that's that's what I wrote about this
week I agree having not read your piece
on this I encountered what I can only
describe as the extreme defiling of palm
trees that takes place in the Southeast
it's something in Florida oh yeah yeah
so in in sort of the opposite
in the past which is on the sea of
Cortez the southern tip of Baja and the
Sea of Cortez usually it's just a lot of
Street lamps but yes they've wrapped the
palm trees which is cool which is why
you would do it the first time but but
they've also wrapped them at least on
the malecon and La Paz in
extraordinarily cold bright white LEDs
like yes right no warmth to them no
subtlety you actually can't look at them
directly without at least for me getting
a headache right away they're so bright
and you know it's it's festive sort of
well myself not really you know with
great lumens comes great responsibility
most people who have this at their
disposal are not using it oh man yeah I
uh
good with great lumens comes great
responsibility would would that those
with the lumens understood that yeah uh
we also of course have merchandise at
our store at darkhorsestore.org
including lie to a tyrant hoodies oh
stickers uh that I actually have a sheet
of Dow that I was going to show you and
I've left off camera which I apologize
but lots lots of cool stuff there and
finally we are supported by our audience
and also our sponsors with regard to our
audience one of which is meowing in the
near distance now
we appreciate you all of you even the
feline members of the audience hello
um
subscribing uh to the channels YouTube
main channel the Dark Horse podcast
Clips Channel
Odyssey channels uh we are of course on
Spotify as well Apple podcasts all the
places uh that you might find podcasts
YouTube is putting ads on our videos now
but they're not paying us anything they
demonetized us get your tongue out of my
water
um
Brett
now our listeners who do not watch are
not going to have any idea what's going
on no that was not that was not kind I'm
sorry that was that was the cat reaching
for my water
um
but you can join either our patreons
which helps us tremendously and we do uh
several monthly conversations Brett has
at his the first Saturday and Sunday of
the month conversations uh for that you
call Evolution Evolution Roundtable and
Coalition of the reasonable something
like that that Coalition of the
reasonable side the other one doesn't
have an official name but it's an
evolutionary discussion that is quite
Lively and lots of
uh folks have been helping to guide the
direction of the discussion and we talk
you know all roads lead to Rome with
respect to Evolution so we can sort of
start anywhere and pursue it excellent
it's great fun and that's not going to
happen for a couple of weeks but
tomorrow we have the private q a that we
both do which you can access at my
patreon and right now the question
asking period is open usually that's the
last Sunday of the month at 11 A.M
Pacific for two hours and we keep we
keep it up so you can you can watch it
anytime if you don't want to join live
but if you join live it's it's a lot of
fun uh the chat is small enough that we
can actually engage with the chat and uh
we're not going to do one on Christmas
this month so we're doing it tomorrow
instead and also at our patreon you can
join the Discord server and get access
to things like coffee hours and book
clubs
and we have sponsors to whom we are very
grateful we start we top of the hour we
do three uh we read ads for three
sponsors whom we have carefully uh
vetted we do not uh have sponsors for
whom we do not actually believe in their
products or or and or have use for or
have someone that we are close to who
has used for them so without further Ado
our ads for this week
our first sponsor this week is all form
we are sitting on an all form sofa right
now right here a reconfigured all-form
sofa because that's one of the things
you can do with these uh these beautiful
pieces of furniture it is yes
um yes this was this was a much larger
sofa and we made it smaller so that we
could fit it all on screen and actually
engage with each other on camera and I
didn't have to didn't have to lay out
any more you know expense you know of
some Sweat Equity right a little sweater
just not very much but not very much so
all form is a company that makes
terrific custom sofas we like them so
much we have two of them and that
doesn't include the extra pieces that
are hanging out as like a Shea's Lounge
from this one in fact we're live stream
I already we already said this yeah
don't say that again
okay we're going to continue to live
stream from this sofa for the
foreseeable future until we get our
permanent Studio set up which who knows
when that's going to be as nice as it
looks it feels even better what makes
the sofa terrific well it's really
pretty right it's it's very nice looking
but then a lot of sofas are nice looking
and then you sit on them and you think I
really don't want to be sitting here for
very long
um that's not the that's not the case
with this one for a fraction of the cost
of traditional sofas you can customize
size layout Fabric and color they do
armchairs love seats all the way up to
an eight seat sectional this is the
easiest way to customize the sofa and
the quality is fantastic and they are
beautiful and comfortable roomy and
adaptable all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home free and fast and
assembly is easy in fact they're so
roomy they're just like they're not
quite perfect for podcasting because
they're deep enough to really you can
really snuggle in so both of us have
like pillows behind us and we're off and
adjusting ourselves not because the sofa
is not comfortable it is but because
it's not too comfortable to pretend that
it's a desk chair right it's not it's
not a match for a desk chair but then
you don't want to a sofa that's a match
for a desk chair
this is an all from sofa in whiskey
leather it's soft and supple and warm
unlike a lot of weather weather yeah a
lot of weather isn't soft up when warm
either but neither is leather and so is
this it looks gorgeous it's incredibly
inviting and comfortable to wear a
combination some people are concerned
about whether or not it holds up to pets
it does the leather is about 20 thicker
that all form uses than typical
Furniture leather and it shows nowhere
despite the fact that both cats and the
dog lie on the couch many evenings
and if you prefer fabric all form
Fabrics are three and a half times more
durable than the industry standard for
heavy duty Fabrics so their Fabrics are
going to hold up really well with pets
as well and they offer a forever
warranty actually forever
to find your perfect self at check out
allforum.com Darkhorse that's
a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com Dark Horse all formers
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at allforum.com Darkhorse
step up your sofa game today
some assembly required pets not included
pets not included no we uh we have we
didn't ask actually but I think it would
not it wouldn't they wouldn't ship I
checked the box there were no pets
included uh well maybe just because you
didn't check the box in advance we're
doing it like you want us to include
pets parakeets Turtles what
okay our second sponsor today is element
that's lmnt element is an electrolyte
drink mix that is everything you need
and nothing you don't it's got a lot of
salt a thousand milligrams of sodium 200
milligrams potassium 60 milligrams of
magnesium has no sugar no coloring no
artificial ingredients no gluten no
fillers electrolytes facilitate hundreds
of functions in the body including the
conduction of nerve impulses hormonal
regulation and nutrient absorption
elements electrolytes can help prevent
and eliminate headaches muscle cramps
and sleeplessness
we've now heard from several friends
about how much they like element for
themselves or in some cases for the
physically hard-working men in their
lives they drink it every day and feel
better doing so
When you sweat the primary electrolyte
loss is sodium athletes can lose up to 7
grams per day elements formulated to
help anyone with their electrolyte needs
and is perfectly suited to folks
following keto low carb or Paleo Diet
element is not just for athletes though
anyone being active may find that they
benefit from element even drinking a few
glasses of wine can leave you depleted
an elephant can help if you're feeling
depleted or dehydrated drink water and
consider element as well right now
element is offering our listeners a free
sample pack with any purchase that's
eight single serving packets free with
any element order this is a great way to
try all eight flavors and you will like
some more than others or share element
with a not yet salty friend
get yours at drinkelement.com Darkhorse
this deal is only available through our
link you must go to
drinklmnt.com Darkhorse element offers
no questions asked refunds try it
totally risk-free if you don't like it
share what you got left with a salty
friend and they will give you your money
back not your salty friend again but
element will give you your money back no
questions asked you have nothing to lose
our final sponsor this week is relief
band a product that can help with nausea
in ancient times nausea was a signal
that something was off and it was useful
nausea was telling you that you had
eaten something you shouldn't have or
were near something emanating a bad
smell itself a signal that you should
not go near it in modernity we still
need to track our bodily sensitivities
we should not always choose to erase
discomfort like nausea when we feel it
but some aspects of modernity create
nausea that does no good at all travel
sickness for instance can be agonizing
and relief would be lovely enter relief
band relief band is an anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to relieve and prevent nausea
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines chemotherapy and more
relief ban is 100 drug free and can be
used for as long as you need it
developed over 20 years ago it is the
only over-the-counter wearable device
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting there are zero side effects and
now there's a relief band sport which is
waterproof features interchangeable
bands and has extended battery life we
asked a friend to try it out and here's
her testimonial I used to have nausea on
a nearly daily basis from anxiety and
the need to take regular medication
relief band relieves my nausea in less
than three minutes and without side
effects I was experiencing from
anti-nausea medication it has entirely
changed my life for the better
so if you've got nausea from anxiety or
car or sea sickness or something else
that you cannot other that is not
otherwise desirable consider relief band
relief band makes a great gift for any
time of year right now they've got an
exclusive offer just for Dark Horse
listeners go to reliefband.com and use
the promo code Darkhorse to receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee that's
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use the
promo code Darkhorse at checkout for
twenty percent off plus free shipping
foreign
[Music]
I think we should start with talking
about
the shadow CDC the shadow CDC yes right
all right well maybe I should do that
having uh encountered the shadow CDC in
person and in fact being uh
I guess a member of it yes and being
shattered right now by an epic Tabby yes
I am um so what has happened is Governor
Ron DeSantis of Florida has made several
announcements he is pursuing a grand
jury investigation of
um malfeasance during covid
um he's doing that uh
as uh Florida's governor the idea being
that Floridians were harmed like every
other group and that we should uh check
out these
um these harms and figure out uh how
they arose and
in any case he has also announced a I'm
not sure I love the term Shadow CDC
frankly I'm not even sure that that is a
term that uh came out officially but
those who are involved with it I've seen
you've seen headlines so what it is is
it's a group of folks with various
different kinds of expertise who have
been impaneled to essentially talk about
what we should be doing with respect to
covid and to comment on what we have
been doing and uh to uh to compare these
things because many of us of course many
Dark Horse
listeners in fact all long-standing dark
horse listeners and viewers will know
that we've been quite disturbed by the
policy that has emerged in the aftermath
um I've covered so I travel to policy
policy is one after another yes all of
the policies
um that uh have followed the emergence
of covis the covet the official
emergence being
um the very final days of 2019 uh many
of us believe that the actual emergence
of the virus was quite a bit earlier
than that
um in fact that there is strong evidence
that what it was circulating at the
Wuhan military games in September I'm
virtually sure it was September of 2019.
so that is among the many errors our
failure to acknowledge that the virus
was circulating uh early is certainly on
that list with significant consequences
um so maybe uh Zach are you ready to
show that clip
all right well I guess we will have to
skip the video from
the event
um
what I said during the event
is
Governor DeSantis and his Surgeon
General Dr ladapo is that his name I
should have asked him in person how to
pronounce it but it's either lit up or
latapo okay I've heard it pronounce both
ways uh pulled together a group of
um
scientists and doctors and medical
doctors
include I don't know if you want to just
mention I would say a few people people
are likely to know uh Jay bhattacharya
is on it Martin koldorf is on it uh I
was on it
um I don't know how I'm gonna pronounce
Tracy's last name it's it's basically
like a Kung name and you have to have
special phonemes in order to get there
but I think the way we traditionally
butchered in English is Tracy Hogue
um Christine stable Ben is on it anyway
it's a and I'm I think there are others
yet to come on the group uh so stay
tuned to see who arrives there but it's
a lot of people who have made important
contributions Jay bharachara and Martin
koldorf of course being
uh primary authors of the Great
Barrington declaration Christine stable
Ben being somebody who our viewers and
listeners will be familiar with from her
excellent unheard uh interview and we
discussed her work revealing that the
MRNA vaccines appear to have to cause an
increase in all-cause mortality
um so anyway all of these people were
gathered several of them virtually there
were I don't know I guess uh six of us
there in person
and we had some back and forth and
um
uh we had several people we had some
vaccine injured folks tell their story
as well it's quite heart-wrenching to
hear what these people have been through
and as I've said many times the
gaslighting of the vaccine injured is
the most among the most shocking things
to emerge in this whole uh in this whole
pandemic because it really requires a
willingness on the part of governmental
bureaucrats to insist that people take a
remedy and then uh pretend that they
have not been injured which just seems
you know one struggles to find words
other than diabolical for that level of
callousness yeah it's it's analogous
it's an imperfect analogy but it's
analogous
to not taking care of your veterans
it is it is exactly the same thing and
how it is that these bureaucrats do not
understand that we will look at how the
vaccine injured were treated and then
the next time they tell us well here's a
vaccine that you must take
right that cannot help but be a primary
factor it would be a factor for any
intelligent person they're creating
actual anti-vaxxers they are creating
they are creating real anti-vaxiness and
you know and they are they are um
fueling it right they are giving it a
credible reason to exist which
is an unthinkable error on their part
um there were a number of things I
wanted to discuss it's pity the the clip
isn't working
um but I will say in my introduction I
argued
that the decision making in and around
covid from the decision to find the
ancestor virus in the wild to bring it
into the lab to enhance its capacity to
infect humans
then they lost control of it presumably
and it got into the human population
they failed to acknowledge that it was
taking place that evidence is
increasingly clear and then they
deployed a strangely top-down response
to this virus which presumably they knew
very little about its effect on humans
because presumably they had not seen it
in humans until it got into somebody and
left the lab so for them to have a
top-down response ready and to enforce
it you know coercively aggressively on
the medical profession is an insane
inversion of the normal order normally
if you had some disease if some disease
really had left out of nature and had
begun infecting humans the people who
would be in the best position to tell
you how to deal with it would be doctors
who had been treating it clinically and
while those doctors would at first have
known nothing what they would have done
is they would have followed hunches they
would have looked at symptoms they would
have said ah this symptom is failing
here are some Pharmaceuticals that are
useful in treating that symptom they
would have deployed those things
deployed techniques some of them would
have worked some of them would not have
worked they would have discussed what
they had seen what they thought was
working you know with other doctors at
the water cooler or and that that we
would have gotten good at treating it to
have it come down from above meant that
process didn't happen and the argument
for for instance lockdowns and mandatory
Universal basking in many places
looks much different if this is just
emerging and we got to shut down travel
and we got to shut down borders and we
got to shut down everything
or this has actually been circulating
for half a year already and now we got
to do this right away we got to do this
as urgent right like you can't create a
sense of urgency in a populace if you
tell them this has been out there for
six months
not only can you not create it but the
utility of trying it is already gone
um this is one of the points that that
Jay bought a truck yeah there's there's
two different there's two different
things like could this potentially be
useful and is it possible to implement
this on a population and those should be
you know you shouldn't you you shouldn't
think about implementing it unless it
could be useful but but they are really
two you know one of them is Downstream
or the other but you need to satisfy
both of those criteria before you decide
to do it before you would decide to do
anything so disruptive yeah and
um so I will Point people to you know
why would they have delayed once the
thing had escaped it seems like uh time
is of the essence and you want people to
be a you know how much time was wasted
doctors seeing a disease that they
didn't know was novel and therefore were
not categorizing it as novel and not
learning the things that they might have
been learning about what to deal with it
right that's one amongst a dozen
different problems that emerge when you
delay that um that awareness
so why would they have delayed it well I
would invite people to go back and look
at our discussion of the time traveling
money printer hypothesis right because
it may be that this was the cynical
recognition by those who did not alert
us that there was something circulating
that they had an opportunity that if
they were willing to uh
prevent us from deploying a rational
response that they were in an excellent
economic position to anticipate the
future and that there's a lot of ways to
turn that into money that was episode
150 and certainly I strongly encourage
people to go back and consider whether
or not that is the explanation but I did
want to highlight one thing from this
um
this meeting in Florida
we first of all I will say there is a
wide range of opinion on this panel
I would say everybody there is a coveted
dissident but we've all arrived at our
positions independently and therefore
those are not the same positions and
this emerged in one interesting place
that I wanted to point to
so in my introduction I argued that from
the sourcing of the ancestral virus in
the wild the enhancing its capacity with
gain of function research and then the
decision making around how to treat it
once it had emerged into the into the
human population
at all told that constitutes the largest
blunder in human history and I believe
it does constitute the largest blunder
in human history there are some equally
terrible or Worse incidents but they're
not blunders so in any case I made this
argument and Martin koldorf picked up on
it and he said Dr Weinstein is right
this is the largest blunder in public
health history or something like that or
words to that effect and we didn't get a
chance there wasn't enough time to have
an interaction about it but what I wish
I had been able to say and mind you
there's nothing negative here about
Martin I I'm a big fan of his work and I
tremendously appreciate the courage he
has shown and the Insight that he has
delivered during the pandemic but he
misunderstood what I said I said it was
the largest blunder in human history and
he took that to be in a medical context
and I wanted to
um defend my position a little bit so
that people can understand so one of the
things that we did disagree on uh within
the panel is whether or not there was a
role for the so-called vaccines in a
rational response to covet and my
position is these vaccines these
vaccines these vaccines right well I
would have loved to have seen a vaccine
that was worth that label that did not
require for example a redefinition of
the term vaccine in order for it to
apply but what we got was a technology
that turned our bodies into vaccine
factories right that's a highly novel
phenomenon and the question is okay
given what they were given what we think
that we thought we understood about
their efficacy
um was there a role for those
Technologies to play and others on the
panel argue that there was a role that
for people who had uh
um comorbidities that made them
especially vulnerable these things might
well have been Justified and I take the
position that these were prototypes that
should never have been injected to human
beings and what I want
to make the argument I want to make now
to clarify why this distinction exists
I believe that those who disagree with
me on this point are
functioning Downstream of a very
honorable and correct Instinct but it
has been miswired not in them but in our
entire context
and what it what it is is I would just
simply say this
if it is true
that the facts of these Technologies the
actual facts of how effective they are
and how dangerous they are mean that
they should not have been emergency use
authorized then it is inherently true
that they should have been given to no
one and my point is given what we know
about these things now given what the
the facts that we have we have learned
as a result of what happened when they
were deployed at wide scale I think it's
very clear that emergency use
authorization made no sense given this
pathogen there was no justification for
taking something that has as many
negative consequences and a serious a
set of negative consequences well and
given that by the time the euas for the
vaccines were being considered there had
been many months of work by clinicians
by by doctors on the ground with
patients discovering what worked and
what didn't and those protocols have
changed over time as the virus has
evolved both because viruses evolve and
presumably because we put greater
selective pressure on it by vaccinating
the population
but the fact is that there were and
remain treatments and given the language
of the emergency use authorization from
the federal government which I read from
back in
gosh it would have been early 2021 on on
Dark Horse there was actually like just
that right there suggests that there was
no justification for an eua because
there were effective treatments
available right that's a that's an
excellent point so this is one of
several points that that had in the same
direction one is what we now see is that
even in the trials that argue that these
things were safe and effective
um the the evidence that they were
neither safe nor effective was already
present and so in light of that an
emergency use authorization should not
be granted the fact that we had safe and
effective treatments among the
repurposed drugs in and of itself should
have killed off the emergency use
authorization and given that they
shouldn't have been given to anybody so
in any case
giving them to people at wide scale in a
completely indifferent way with respect
to the age stratification of the risks
of the vaccines so-called vaccines
um and the risk stratification in
exactly the inverse form in their
potential value
these things should have been DOA they
should never have been authorized and in
light of that the authorization and
everything Downstream of it strikes me
as illegitimate
okay but they've saved so many lives
really can we go there sure all right
um many listing will have heard uh that
code vaccines saved One Million Lives no
wait it's actually three million
correction and and reduced
hospitalizations by like 18 million I
think this is the US only or is it is
the U.S only US Open
um and uh for instance
apologies I was going to I did not have
this queued up because I thought we were
going to show that video that didn't
work so
um
here's a
apologies I really had not queued this
up
so here's just a typical tweet about no
hold on about the research that is being
alluded to new study I just took off the
person tweeting it because I don't she
doesn't need to be dragged for this in
particular although she should really
wake up since she claims to be a medical
doctor new study out shows that covid-19
vaccines have averted over 3 million
deaths 18 million hospitalizations and
saved one trillion dollars in medical
costs in the U.S and it's a link to an
article at
commonwealthfund.org hold on
um two years and
commonwealthfund.org two years of U.S
covid-19 vaccines have prevented
millions of hospitalizations
so I actually have Zachary a PDF of that
to show where I've got some stuff
highlighted let me just make it uh full
screen here okay you can show it now so
this is a PDF we will also
link to the link to the article on the
web this is the research in question
this is the research that finds that
three million deaths in the US have been
averted with these vaccines and 18
million hospitalizations and saved a
trillion dollars okay and it's out of
it's you know University of Maryland and
Yale and Yale School of Public Health
and all sorts of important places
well yes this research how how pray tell
did they uh did they manage to wrestle
this pattern from the data yeah well as
it turns out this is literally a blog
post so let's just start there like I'm
burying the lead here but this is
literally a blog post now this thing has
now been cited by well apparently
Anthony fauci himself this research is
now the biggest news in how amazing the
code vaccines are this is literally a
blog post this is from the same category
of people the same class of people who
throughout code when many of us have
been talking about papers on pre-print
servers that haven't yet been peer
reviewed oh you can't talk about that
because until it's been peer-reviewed
it's not real science this is a blog
post there aren't even any references
it's not even that they didn't include
the references but they clearly have
them there aren't even any references
Okay so
this ain't research they may have done
research and we're going to get to what
in fact they claim to have done but this
is all that is available that all of the
headlines and all of the doctors online
are referring to is a report in which
all of the actual stuff that was done is
completely opaque that's not how science
works okay so two connections one we've
seen this trick before Oh so many times
so many times the together trial right
we had a slide from a presentation for
more than half a year before they even
showed us the methods section which then
took experts weeks to unpack but it's
the Yale School of Public Health could
go wrong I mean these These are the
experts these are the authorities I'm
sure they've got glassware I'm sure
they've got lab coats I know they've got
the relevance I'm not sure they have any
of those things I know what they've got
though
grant money
um so can we show uh the clip of Anthony
fauci referring to this piece of
research before we get to what yeah I
think it's kind of the right order to do
it excellent yes let's do it so Zach has
that yeah
but the latest now Dr fauci is Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis he's now asking
the Florida Supreme Court to Green Light
an investigation into in the way he put
it is any uh any and all wrong doing in
Florida with respect to covid-19
vaccines
what's your reaction to that
I don't have a clue Kate what he's
asking for I mean we have a vaccine that
unequivocally is highly effective and
safe and has saved literally millions of
lives the Commonwealth fund has come out
with a report just this past week that
vaccinations that have been administered
over this period of time this last year
and a half to two years has saved 3.2
million lives 18 million
hospitalizations and approximately one
trillion dollars in costs so what's the
problem with vaccines I mean vaccines
are life-saving so quite frankly Kate
I'm not sure what what they're trying to
do down there it kind of gets at a
bigger issue I've been wanting to ask
you as in one of our final interviews in
in your role in public health is just
the res one result of the pandemic has
sadly been that science has become a
divisive topic politicized sized and
weaponized by some people
have you thought about how do you pull
that back how do you turn that around
you know Kate if I had an easy answer I
I'd give it to you but it's a very
difficult situation you're absolutely
correct it has been politicized and it
has been politicized in a way that has
actually caused lives because if people
don't get
all right so that was unfortunately I
haven't seen that and I the way we have
things set up I couldn't hear it so I
don't know what he said so and that was
Anthony fauci
um in response to the question about
what governor DeSantis is doing with his
call for a grand jury that is Anthony
fauci saying I don't know what Ron
DeSantis is up to the vaccines have
saved you know a report out this week
says the vaccines have saved more than 3
million lives
so you know what they actually did
I do
they uh
they took the assumption that vaccines
save lives
and they plug that into their model and
they said now let's imagine a universe
with vaccines that save lives and
without vaccines that save lives
and see if at the end of that running of
that simulation the universe in which
the vaccines which do save lives have
saved lives like at the end of the
simulation are more lives saved in a
universe in which vaccines that save
lives exist or
are there more lives saved in a world
without vaccines that do save lives
we they started with the conclusion
which we've also seen over and over and
over again and then they why law acted
surprised when out popped their results
so
in a model which is not data right they
plugged in an assumption which would
automatically give them an astronomical
number for the number of lives saved so
specifically just in terms of what they
did Zach if you would show my screen
again
this again this so-called research that
everyone is alluding to the the thing
that is not a research paper in any way
at the very end there's a how we
conducted the study section which in a
normal paper would be right after the
introduction between the introduction
the results and would actually spell out
precisely what was done and would
reference all of the claims that are in
any way not general knowledge already
how we conducted the study at the end of
this blog post
is
them saying basically what I just said
and then
vaccine efficacies against infection and
symptomatic and severe disease for
different vaccine types for each variant
and by time since vaccination we're
drawn from published estimates
that's it right that is the evidence
that is and and we don't even know what
the published estimates are
well this is this is Beyond scientific
malpractice yes this is this is complete
Insanity and is being you know all the
CNN viewers are now convinced that saint
fauci has spoken the word of God because
the Yelp School of Public Health has
just done this research which no like
they did something for sure but they put
out a blog post in which they buried the
actual thing that they did by saying
that their evidence that these vaccines
are effective was drawn from published
estimates what estimates were those how
were those gathered and were they
themselves accurate that is what we need
to know to know if the vaccine saved
lives they didn't they did not assess
anything to do with whether or not the
vaccine's actually saved lives here
right now I think there have been a
number of good analyzes of this and they
have discovered where the bodies are
buried here or not buried as the case
may be meaning they have they have
actually found the references they have
found the model on which these things
are built because this is of course the
second report from this group and so
there's a history right the model in
which it's built is one thing but like
the the the the
estimates I would Point people to Brett
Swanson's uh substack he's a data
analyst who has been excellent on uh on
questions regarding covet and he reveals
that this model in this case requires an
estimate of the number of people who
would have died from covid that
consistently exceeds the maximum number
that ever did on a daily basis right so
they have simply taken an absurd number
in light of a uh okay but that but
that's a different question I mean
that's that's a different problem with
the model right the problem that I'm
pointing out is they they have made the
claim that the vaccines save lives right
like far aside from the actual research
that we can see that they did here which
is
um which is given that we started with
the assumptions that we can't we won't
tell you exactly how we made them and
exactly the nature of what they were but
now let's start with these these these
models of of sort of the population and
such that that's the level you're
talking about because that is
transparent-ish if you know how to read
this blog post right now what you're
saying is and I totally agree with this
this is a this is fraud because it's
being done by people who understand why
you can't do this this isn't high school
students right these are presumably
people who have studied the data sets
and know what you can and cannot do I
wouldn't have passed this paper if it
came to me in in as a college because it
doesn't matter what level of study
you're at this is perfectly circular
what they did is they told older model
that these were highly effective
vaccines at saving lives and then they
asked them whether they were highly
effective at saving lives it's perfectly
circular yes now
if you
for those of us who saw that clip of
fauci on CNN saying basically parroting
this as if it was a result which it is
not right it is a model right
for somebody like fauci to invoke that
number taken from this Source tells you
something that many people have been
reluctant to accept
this is a knowing lie all right Dr fauci
has plenty of training and a tremendous
amount of experience he knows the
difference between this and a result
that shows that this has happened so I
actually like with the amount of
skepticism that I've had to keep
actively on board for the last three
years now
I really thought I'm missing something
like this blog post is linking like i i
s and I still hope I'm wrong like where
is the research guys it's
well but it's it's not here but okay
take the alternative hypothesis which is
that from whatever point it happened
there was some idea of what we were
going to do and from that point every
decision has been subordinated to
whether it supports that plan or argues
against it and so any piece of evidence
that would get in the way of your
vaccinate everyone program has been uh
obscured and every uh result no matter
how garbagey no matter how circular no
matter how much it is based on models
that are not actually evidence of
anything it is it is promoted to the
very highest levels right to have
Anthony fauci on CNN say a knowing lie
and it can't be anything else
incompetence does not explain why
somebody with a full career's worth of
experience in this exact field would
parent a result this dumb he's a lot of
things but dumb bunny he ain't he ain't
a dumb bunny
um so and then but the this result
you've probably seen it you and I have
not been together since this result came
out we've been in separate places but
I've seen it in many many different
places everybody on the blue team is
championing this as like see we were
right new data right no actually no new
data at all now nothing so this is
actually a good moment to reveal that
Tony is in fact our Lord and savior if
you could show my screen here this
editor-in-chief of Science magazine this
week published this editorial in science
the headline is thank you Tony
okay so he the editor-in-chief of
Science magazine one of the two premier
science journals in the world uh has
done an interview with Tony fauci and
he's just put some of the highlights
into this thing and then you can go
listen I have not uh you can go listen
to the whole interview if you like
um Anthony fauci Tony to friends
colleagues so many journalists has never
backed down from controversy it begins
just a few quotes here
we talked a lot about this the
editor-in-chief of Science and Tony
fauci we talked a lot about
misinformation and the forces sowing
doubts about covid-19 vaccinations
interventions such as masks and
lockdowns
did you
love to hear that we agreed that one of
the biggest challenges with which the
scientific Community must grapple is
misinformation that comes from within
I ran to that like a stone wall at a
congressional hearing he said describing
how his skepticism of an argument put
forward by researchers who questioned
the necessity of Copenhagen lockdowns
was met with admonishment quote you're
arrogant because you're disrespecting
other scientists he was told fauci's
response quote you don't want to be
disparaging of anyone but you've got to
come back and push against those things
that are not true
I like this is so backwards and upside
down and one more thing we also talked
about how we need to do a better job of
conveying that science is a process and
not a collection a collection of facts
set in stone nowhere is it a guy named
Anthony fauci frankly
well okay but so can you can you believe
this guy I don't like the way they've
titled this I think it really should
have been titled oh Tony your science is
so big
science Me Harder Tony or something
right
no but it's the Christmas season so I
think all right so they toned it down
for their kids but no he's he's Christ I
mean they're making them and they're
they are they are and you know well
that's that's a that's a promotion
because he was just science before and
now now he's both now he's
ascended yes he is ascended in his uh
stepping down from from his former role
um but okay
this is frankly right if there wasn't so
much writing on all this this is funny
right the fact that people cannot help
but die from the terrible advice and
treatments they're getting makes this
utterly ghastly but the absurdity of it
would be funny otherwise but I wanted to
point out this isn't just
the science types and the science
journals getting tangled in knots about
this and your doctor giving you bad
advice the public it's not just all of
that it's not just all of that what's
happened is they have carved out the
space to make a completely fictional
scientific reality that is not obligated
to match anything in the actual real
world anymore and everybody who you know
signed up for the idea that they were
the real scientists is now being carried
into this fantasy Science World along
with them can you show the um the
Stephen Colbert clip
uh
fives
so to take full command of the GOP all
DeSantis has to do is reel in the
coveted conservative demographic of
angry conspiracy Q Anon all meat diet
tand your testicle boys
[Applause]
and his opening offer to all of them is
calling for a grand jury investigation
of covid vaccines
you stupid motherfizer
questions
you want an investigation let me save
you some time and money in the U.S alone
the coveted vaccines have saved more
than 3 million lives and help prevent
and helps prevent
18.5 million hospitalizations and
if that's not enough and because idiots
in your party politicize the vaccine
almost twice as many Republicans died
from covid before the midterms than the
Democrats y'all killed your own boaters
it's the stupidest political strategy
since the Whig slogan of 1840 Tippecanoe
and taunted grizzly
all right now that I think was it the
drummer in the background that they
showed I feel like there was one person
in the band I think the drummer the
woman in the background who did not look
thrilled
I have hopes I I you have hoped yeah
well what shocks me about that I mean
not only has this blog post taken on a
life of its own as if it were just true
it did come out of the Yale School of
Public I don't I guess it did but
um not only is it being uh
rendered into this phony reality as if
it was actually like three million
people alive who otherwise wouldn't be
right a complete bit of nonsense but the
uproarious laughter and Applause at this
the idea that this is so transparently
correct that this audience of
sophisticated people is you know ready
to just laugh at the beauty of what
we've done with these things it's
tribalism and it's dehumanizing it's you
know this this continues this you know
blue team loves to argue that it was
Trump who turned the American political
system into the complete Carnival that
it is today that it was yeah it was
going there and like you know Newt
Gingrich started in the 90s and all of
this and it goes all the way back but it
was really Trump who did it and
they need it now and I God is that the
first time I've referred to them as them
maybe but you know blue team needs the
division needs the dehumanization needs
the tribalism in order to keep
I don't even know what they're trying to
keep it they're trying to keep the power
and the fact is they actually can't
afford not to have the power yeah
because
um what they've done is
so dangerous and so harmful and frankly
if one is allowed to do a proper
investigation it's not that hard to
prove right these are not it's not a
complicated question at a scientific
level you know did these so-called
vaccines uh increase the level of
all-cause mortality or didn't they right
that's a relatively straightforward
thing to test as as Christine stable Ben
has shown and um so her work was better
than this work I'm about to show you
um but also this week
nature an editorial if you will show
this Zachary missing data means we'll
probably never know how many people died
of covid
huge discrepancies and estimates of
excess mortality revealed not just how
difficult the calculations are but how
far the world has to go in recording how
people die now
excess mortality
like estimates Hospitality specifically
don't require that you know how people
died that's the point right that is that
is the point also this editorial I was
going to walk through how stupid it is
but I'm not currently so again we've
already had
science anointing fouchy as the
next coming of Jesus Christ and now we
have in the same weak nature the other
preeminent science journal in the world
with this Pap and they are referring to
an article that they published this week
out of
um
called The Who estimates of excess
mortality associated with the Copa 19
pandemic and in this article we have
figure one which has Global access and
reported covid-19 deaths and death rates
per hundred thousand population
now this is cumulative
but
um check out how covid was killing
people and then
um the rate increased
in 2021
and then this is not cumulative this is
just
um reported covid-19 death rate per 100
000. this is figure 1B of the same
article that just came out the death
rate per 100 000 and covet was killing
people Northern summer of 2020 uh it
dipped slightly and then it boy did it
start killing people again except it's
not that covid was killing people right
it's that we have excess mortality right
so it's the red line so I'm reading that
like someone I was saying that as if
someone might look at this go like oh my
God look at all the Koba deaths like no
we have
deaths attributed to covert with the red
line and we have excess mortality with
the purple line here and the purple line
has some has some spikes
um honestly right around
the rollout of the vaccine and then
right around when suddenly everyone had
access to the vaccine and you can't say
from this that it was covid or it was
the vaccine or it was hepatitis or it
was cancer it was heart disease it was
anything but what you can do is you can
say
let's look at data on excess mortality
which is death counts that's all it
takes death counts compare it to
previous death counts and then
separately let's look at all of the
things that happen in the world to which
particular spikes might be attributed so
this is consistent the whose report
political nature this week is consistent
with Ben's work from earlier
but somehow the nature news report the
editorial version of nature instead
reports this headline missing data mean
we'll probably never know how many
people died of coven
that's actually not the message of the
work they're reporting on yeah well it's
funny it's like I mean we know that
people in many places worst of all
science but many places people report
you know they read the title of a paper
that leans in some Direction they want
or they read the title in the abstract
and they don't delve any further than
this they cite it because they're
they've become advocates for some
position and the thing seems to push in
that direction so it doesn't almost
matter what it says right and so in some
sense this phony world that they've
created the phony Tony world is
um
basically hungry for stuff that you can
point to for your laugh line if you're
Stephen Colbert or whatever but it's
just stuff it doesn't matter that
there's anything underneath it it can
just be an assertion that comes from a
place like Yale right and it's good
enough and so that you know whoa boy
that sounds like a sophisticated
analysis that the there's missing data
that's going to prevent us from ever
knowing right they want to seed the idea
oh we're never going to know why are we
never gonna know because we're never
going to do the right study and why are
we never going to do the right study
because a lot of people can't afford for
us to do the right study it's not hard
the data isn't missing yes it will be
noisy but you know do you know what
those giant buildings full of people who
do science are about
knowing how to study questions like this
and and frankly once once you've paired
it all away and you've you've you know
you've realized that oh my God uh the
PCR tests aren't the right things to be
testing for this and died with versus
died of covet is really messy and we're
never going to fully untangle that
the measure of excess mortality doesn't
require any of that it doesn't require
that we untangle any of that doesn't
require that that's the beauty of it any
of it it is so beautiful it is so simple
and yes if there's something else that
happened in late 2019 early 2020 or in
late 2020 early 2021 through now that we
are yet unaware of we will potentially
mistake one one pattern for the other
but excess mortality simply looks at how
many people died and historically at the
same time of year how many people died
and how many more are there yeah well
and you know even even if there were
something that magically showed up at
that same moment right we have various
different countries in which we had
different patterns and so you can unpack
that as well there's nothing here that
is beyond study this this is not harder
than your average question in fact this
is so much easier than we are making it
out to be and unfortunately we're now I
think the new game is
um that they've reversed the burden of
proof which is one of their favorites
yeah right that that's what happened uh
with these people who are extremely high
quality scientists on desantis's panel
the reason that we disagree is that
they've had the burden of proof reversed
on them and so they're trying to be very
careful because they've spent careers
being careful but the problem is careful
has been flipped on its head you know so
um
there's no reason I will point out it's
not the only thing that went missing
according to this uh report do you
notice that Pfizer's document its
agreement with Israel went missing I
don't what what report what are we
talking about the the report that you
just put up saying that the uh
um the uh data has is missing and that
it will prevent us from knowing who
whether or not we've had a increase in
oh some something else is kind of
messing something else it is the
agreement between Pfizer and the state
of Israel has apparently also gone
missing it's just gone they don't know
yeah um apparently they had someone in
over the weekend to clean up and so
anyway it's possible she placed it
somewhere but that'll happen yeah
it does happen yeah right I mean sure
um
but yeah Israel should really get its
act together it's very disorganized and
not you know not able to get things done
in general right right
no that's like every other nation-state
after I mean let's you know let's let's
steal man their argument I mean Israel
you know it's a small country but it's
still a big place there are a lot of
places they could have you know so
they're some presumably they haven't
checked absolutely right they're gonna
have to do a systematic check of all of
the Cubbies and other small places in
Israel that this document could be
hiding um right and oh and that's before
they even get to the computers I was
just gonna say not to not to say
anything about
um the virtual Universe right that yeah
the number of so many Cubbies yeah
Israel inside their computers there's
got to be I mean hundreds of places that
document could hide
maybe even order some magnitude more
than that
who knows
um
so
um here's another thing that happened
this week okay
um the White House had a summit on stem
equity and inclusion really yeah uh I
watched it
I'm not sure why
this is stem stem yes
um which I'd never seen before that
acronym science technology engineering
math and medicine
and uh I guess it's because I subscribe
to science because
I still feel like I need to and I don't
have an Institutional affiliation
because they've all gone completely
insane and so I got an announcement the
morning of hey we're doing this though
we're streaming the White House Summit
on stem Equity inclusion sponsored by
science like okay let's go look
um so there's a lot to say but I just
and and you know it wasn't
it wasn't entirely ridiculous but
um because we have a lot of other things
that we're talking about today I will
restrict my comments to
to
quoting the president of Harvey Mudd
College whose name I failed to write
down I apologize
um concludes her comment she's on one of
many panels and she concludes her
comments by saying so Harvey Mudd
College is one of the Claremont colleges
it is a very small very elite uh mostly
engineering school a stem School
basically stem with 1M
um and uh you know advise as she claims
but it's true it advise for
undergraduates I think it's entirely
undergraduate I'm not sure about that
actually
um with the likes of MIT and Caltech and
uh
and she has some good things to say you
know she she talks about she and others
talk about the science of belonging
which sounds ridiculous but um actually
the idea that when you walk into a
classroom you shouldn't assume that you
belong because of your demographics nor
should you assume that you don't belong
Pacific demographics and the professor
and everyone else in the room should
also not make those assumptions and this
is something that we did without ever
hearing of those signs of belonging
right in the classroom but the idea that
actually uh College administrators and
and faculty are waking up to this you
know decades too late uh is at least
something valuable but she concludes her
comments by saying that on campus quote
we also continuously celebrate our
cultural value that every person every
student every faculty member every staff
member is responsible for the success of
every other person on campus
that struck me as something that could
just be
washed away ignored whatever okay do you
think you're doing good for people and
helping you know raise Everyone by not
making sure that no one is left behind
but
this strikes me as insane completely
insane completely anti-meritocratic
um
opposed to the idea of striving on your
own for instance
or being held responsible for your own
failures both of both of those things
are are weakened by the idea that you
no matter how good you are and or how to
how bad you are at whatever it is that
you're trying to do are responsible for
the success of everyone around you
well no you're not
you know it's funny because I remember
running into what is effectively a
different version of the same concept I
remember running into it the first time
and it was as Evergreen was coming apart
and the claim
which again these claims they sound so
lovely right on first hearing but the
claim was that
Evergreen had a very serious problem
because people graduated with different
levels of capability and the idea was
that Evergreen was actually morally
required to ensure that everyone
graduated equally capable that's
Harrison Bergeron University right and I
heard that and I thought God there is
only one way to do that which is to
hobble those who are highly capable even
if they were right which they weren't
but even if they were right that these
disparities were the result
of unfairness right that was based on
sex or race or whatever even if they
were correct the idea that somebody who
enters College gifted in math right has
to basically
graduate with people who are either
brought up to their level which will be
impossible right because you can't take
somebody who has no math skill and bring
them up to the most capable person's
level or they will have to be sabotaged
for four years and and it's like they
don't
they don't first of all I'm not even
sure you know that they wouldn't come up
with you euphemisms for sabotage that of
course that would make them comfortable
but they don't they wouldn't even stop
upon hearing that and thinking oh yeah
now we can't have everybody graduate at
the same level because that means
ruining everybody's capacity that they
have right right the only level you can
equalize them all to is completely
incapable right that's the only
achievable place where that can happen
and you would be a fool
to go to a school to matriculate at a
school that had that as it's what does
she say
cultural value
that that would be an insane place to go
if they really are serious about it in
fact this is an argument that I made in
an email to our colleagues at Evergreen
I said you can't do this because nobody
you are effectively talking about
transferring
um educational well-being from certain
students to other students and the
students from whom you are transferring
it will simply not show up right why
people get your wish because the
standards will plummet well the
standards will plummet but the point is
you need all of those you know this was
not a rich College it needs a student
body willing to come and pay tuition and
you know to the extent that you're going
to drive those who are most capable off
you know it doesn't matter whether they
were capable for reasons that ultimately
come from unfairness you need them to
show up in order to have a college and
um well you also need the most capable
people to show up to
to be awesome to inspire to educate
others to provide foils for the faculty
to help bring the other students who
maybe maybe are less capable because
they've been disadvantaged and could
become more capable but they need to be
able to hear the conversation some
people are less capable because they're
just less capable
but a lot of people are less capable
because they've been disadvantaged but
they're not going to learn how to be
more capable if the only people they're
surrounded with are also not capable
like that's not how Learning Happens no
it's it's uh it's complete
um complete nonsense and the irony of
ironies in the case of of our former
College
was that our former College was unique
in the fact that it was really well
designed to deal with high potential
people who hadn't been well served by
whatever system they came from right it
was well positioned awesome yeah they
really were and the
possibility to take people who had high
potential but hadn't been reached by
anybody and give them a Lifeline was a
mission that that Evergreen was uniquely
positioned to address and it's so
rewarding my God it's so amazing to you
know it at a moment when people are
claiming claiming that you know everyone
needs to be forced to succeed on you
know on the rubric that someone else has
created who maybe never even met a kid
right and then to actually be able to
to kind of like open up the world
to people who know that they're hungry
but don't know what they're hungry for
and maybe haven't even really ever had a
meal like here this is this is a bunch
of options you start making choices and
then maybe you start getting funneled
here or there but how extraordinary you
know as opposed to no just accept that
because the first 18 years of your life
you didn't get good education or you had
an unfortunate family situation or you
know or or you were malnourished or you
were any number of things well then just
give up now like no we need institutions
we need
more than functional outstanding
institutions that do not
uh discriminate against students who
didn't have advantages but have
extraordinary potential and Evergreen
was that place and I don't think there
is a place now that does it and it is it
is ideas like this that apparently I'd
forgotten actually you would you had
heard at Evergreen I heard come from the
current president of Harvey Mudd College
an elite school as if this is an
honorable thing to be doing and it's not
it's it's the death of the University
yeah I mean it's you know it it's
cognitive communism and the point is
right look the problem with us try not
to use the word but yeah this is what it
is yeah the problem with all versions of
Communism is that it's an empty space
it's not a real place you can go right
it's not obvious that it would be
desirable if you could go there but it
doesn't work right and the theoretical
solution set you want to have it taking
taking a play a space but it's not
available in design space it is
inherently self unstable and doesn't
accomplish the things you need to
accomplish in order to make a
civilization work it doesn't accomplish
the things you need to make a university
work and so the question is all right in
light of the fact that communism is both
sucky and impossible right what else
might we do hey here's an idea how about
we increase everybody's capacity as much
as we can in the brief period of time we
have contact with them right wouldn't
that be cool if I may buy an allergy in
light of the fact that the vaccines are
neither safe nor effective what else
what else anybody got anything else
possible there's another possibility on
the table Yeah anybody anything
anybody and then you know the next thing
is overlooking Dr Corey Dr bhattachary
and all of these other every other folks
yeah no it's sucky and impossible yeah
but other than that like yes yeah
anything better like yes we got lots of
better things that we haven't yet
declared evil you know
okay well that's all very well and good
and you know I understand it's important
to talk about future humanity and
Society everything but sometimes
sometimes instead of covid and public
health and nature viruses and how not to
do science and how to convince people
that the fact that they don't understand
science should really mean that they
should learn how to understand science
and admit that that's what they've been
doing is the opposite sometimes
what I actually want to think about is
not any of those things but about
whether or not female snakes experience
sexual pleasure
wow all right didn't see that coming but
I didn't yeah no
um
maybe I should just leave it there
well it depends do you know the answer
there's some new research out oh that's
actually good was it a model that
decided that they don't experience
pleasure because the model told them
that they didn't experience pleasure
it's not that that's right well okay so
I'm actually I'm gonna I'm gonna not
say yet exactly what it is I will I will
say
um just a little bit first about
phylogeny and about
um character Evolution which sounds you
know we start with
female sexual pleasure we're going to
character Evolution what the hell
um snakes are lizards uh which usually
even phylogenesis who study snakes uh or
Lizards will when they're talking about
the group that includes
snakes will say lizards and snakes even
though snakes are lizards so together
the lizards and the snakes are the
squamates the squamada
and um the squamata have as every good
clay monophyletic clay that is there is
there is a point in time when that clade
originated and it is Diversified
radically and so that clade is
monophyletic it includes all of its
descendants of that first uh of that
first Proto squamate and there are
characters that is in normal parlance
you would say characteristics although
evolutionary biologists say characters
there are characters that diagnose the
clade even though you members of that
clade could then lose those characters
and that doesn't mean that they lose
their um
diagnosed doesn't mean that the clade is
sick
um well for so so things that you would
recognize would be that mammals have as
these diagnostic characters
synapomorphies in the technical language
of evolutionary biology have for
instance mammary glands and
um but not
um yeah mammary glands but not nipples
because the monotremes the echidnas and
the Platypus you ain't a kidney at the
base of the mammal tree actually don't
have nipples but they don't have mammary
glands and fur is a diagnostic
characteristic and that you know you can
you can lose your fur as we have and you
remain a mammal but it was a character
that diagnosed the origin of of the
clade and so um a synapomorph he had
diagnosed a shared derived character of
squirmates which is again lizards and
six is having hemipines which is two
reversible
pins which is really how it's pronounced
I would have said penises but as a
herpetologist I just say someone who
studies the creepy crawlies that include
the amphibians and reptiles
um I know that you're supposed to
pronounce it hemipins so for those of
you tuning in late Heather has not had a
stroke she's just teaching you how to
speak about the phylogeny of snakes and
lizards well I also think it's super
amusing to start with uh sexual pleasure
and female snakes and then go
immediately into the really dry stuff oh
don't be a beakhead
which are not
they are not lizards but these are no
the scissors their sister tuatars
because wrinklesophilians I believe
sister to squamous if I remember
correctly they
yes they're not sister to lizards oh I
guess I guess they are yes because
lizards include snakes got it I've
caught up now I've had my stroke
which is these shared two uh reversible
meaning they can they can be tucked into
the body and they come out
um penises
um peons it's peens actually
um that males have on every male
squamate and they're used alternatively
during successive mating so if you've
ever seen snakes mate which like I
recommend it actually it's kind of
interesting lizards too
um they they go at it from the side and
so like lizards will like wrap wrap
themselves around each other and if you
are able to watch them long enough if
they don't mind you watching them and
you follow them because this is what
herpetologists do in the field sometimes
you will see that it's the same pair or
even if just the same male you see him
made another time
um he will he will use his other penis
he will use the other side
so there's a lot of diversity across
squamates that is again lizards and
snakes in size in shape other
characteristics like some of them are
spiny some of those spines but not all
of them and
this has all been known for a long time
um I actually didn't look up how long
how many peons have been understood to
be the one of the diagnostic
characteristics of squamous but it's
been a long time and hat tip here to our
friend
um from from grad school Jennifer OST
who pointed me to this new research and
she in turn hat tipped her and my
graduate advisor Arnold cluge
because apparently and I was never
somehow I missed out on his soliloquies
about how all the research into
hemipines
um always avoided talking about the
um the the compatible part in females
which would be it's not pronounced
hemichitrises is it's hemi-clitaris I
guess okay
so here we are here we go
um apparently Kluge my graduate advisor
has been arguing for decades that know
what female snakes have is not just
underdeveloped hemipines thank you very
much
which of course because herpetology even
more than many fields within biology was
very dominated by men for a very long
time and because female genitalia in
general is considered like oh do we have
to I don't know and it's a little less
obvious and all of this to the degree
that anything was ever noticed in female
snakes it was usually kind of like okay
that's just underdeveloped heavy pins
nothing to see there let's move along
and so you know hats off to clergy for
you know well before his time being like
no I don't think so I think there's
something there there well wait a second
do we have any idea how many parties
clergy ruined by mentioning this
I suspect having been at only a very few
parties that clingy was at that he was
the life of many yes I actually think
that he was the life of many parties and
that this probably caused an awkward
silence of maybe 30 seconds to a minute
and a half and then people would move
right along on the other hand you invite
uh invite Arnold clergy to a party you
probably know what you're getting
yourself into yeah you did it to
yourself pretty much you did it to
yourself okay so I'm just going to read
a couple things from this fabulous new
paper yeah this is published in uh the
proceedings of the Royal Society
uh first evidence of hemichitary is in
snakes uh from out of University of
Adelaide and Mount Holyoke and actually
University of Michigan Museum of zoology
which was of course where
um where
Jennifer and I were working with cluge
and and he wasn't on your committee but
he wouldn't you were also his his
student yep uh so the very first
sentence of the abstract of this paper
female genitalia are conspicuously
overlooked in comparison to their male
counterparts limiting our understanding
of sexual reproduction across vertebrate
lineages I would say they are
inconspicuously overlooked conspicuously
and they're like well conspicuous to
some people
um the overlooking is conspicuous yeah
yes yeah exactly so later in the
abstract histology of the hemichliteris
and Australian death adders acanthophys
antarcticus showed erectile tissue and
strands and bundles of nerves but no
spines as is found in male hemipins
these histological features suggest the
snake hemichitaries have functional
significance in mating and definitively
show that the hemic
hemichitaries are not underdeveloped
hemipines or set glands which have been
erroneously indicated in other studies
so first off just notice
care and the rigor of the scientific
argument here
's what hemipines have here's what we
are finding in the death actors I love
what they use death they actually use
nine species but they went deep on the
death adders
um that's just so that they would have a
story that's like that's like studying
lichen on the face of El Capitan right
yeah I know I mean they do it in Death
matters you know the first author is at
the University of Adelaide so um
although everyone else is that I don't
know there's two authors in Australia
um
but they said okay so the the existing
hypotheses are it's just um scent glands
or it's underdeveloped hemipines if it
was underdeveloped hemipines you would
expect to see the same structures in
hemipines but less so and what they're
saying is now we did the dissections we
did the histology no no and no it's
they're they're it's different it is
presumably homologous
um the the hemichitaries in the female
Death headers adders and the hemipines
in the male death adders but one is not
just a like a half-assed version of the
other sorry no and this is the story of
research on female sexuality in general
not just in humans but in
snakes snakes as well so genitalia are
some of the fastest following
characteristics of amniotes with
internal fertilization so that
don't get me started on that but that's
fascinating because sexual selection
drives rapid Evolution because sexual
selection drives rapid Evolution but
specifically the question of internal
fertilization so
um so because the shape of the
structures then is relevant to the
sexual selection
yes that's that's
so the piece that I would love to be
talking about but I won't do here for
fear of losing more of our audience
is the conditions under which internal
fertilization versus external
fertilization evolve and what happens
when you have uh you know once you have
internal fertilization live birth versus
egg birth versus OVO Viva parity which
is like you have eggs inside your body
that then hatch so that you give birth
to something live but there wasn't any
Plus on tall fetal transfer of of
nutrients or resources along the way all
of these are fascinating actually snakes
make a an excellent system for looking
at the diversity of of within internal
fertilization of those types of types of
birth
variation in clitoris morphology has
been linked to different degrees of
sexual arousal that could lead to
increased reproductive Fitness by
enticing females to copulate or forming
social bonds so this is the authors in
the introduction way of saying guess
what guys this actually matters like
this this is relevant it is interesting
and it does matter if you think you're
interested in sexual selection
Evolution at all really Behavior social
bonding all of these things
and then they say again even when
hemichitaries are described in lizards
these have been hypothesized to provide
a stimulatory role for the male during
intro mission right so to the degree
that there are like
potent you know tissues in female
genitals that could provide pleasure no
it's probably just to provide the male
pleasure like this is literally what's
in the literature well it also implies
it's a very long movie if there's an
intermission
so I will say you know this already
um
intro mission is different from
intermission ah okay
um okay uh just a couple more things
here
um unlike lizard Hemi clitories all
snake Hemi clitories examine lacked
spines sulcus spermaticus and retractor
muscles and could not be inverted by
manual manipulation suggesting that
something different interesting is going
on going on in snakes and I think
there's one more thing I don't need to
show the clitories in detail ah
um
the presence of erectile bodies with
blood cells suggests that the
hemichitaries engorge with blood while
the presence of abundant nerve bundle
suggests that their stimulation May
provide sensory feedback to the females
so um maybe that's that's all I'll share
from the paper right now you can't of
course
um interview steaks and ask them about
their choice of Partners or whether or
not they're choosing to engage now
because they're sexually aroused but you
also can't do the kinds of things that
you would do in even other mammals and
look at you know basically measure
emotion in the same way you can't you
know you can't look you can't do the
same kind of analyzes so especially if
you've chosen to do it in death adders
would be dangerous can I just have never
mind it's you just know about your
business
um
but so they've done
they've done exactly the work that you
would you would want to have done if you
were interested in whether or not female
snakes experience sexual pleasure which
is okay there's actually structures here
and no they're not just kind of halfway
to what the males have they're actually
distinct structures and they both have
erectile capability and abundant nerve
bundles and they seem to do the same
thing that clitoris apparently is the
plural do in all the other species that
have them and yes they did it in death
adders and eight other species of sex
okay but so I mean this is the nature of
science right because each study reveals
the next question that you want to
answer but it sounds like they did not
answer the question all right you've got
snakes with Hemi clitor eye but they
don't say what fraction of male snakes
are aware that female snakes have
hemichitarized yes yes the male snakes
are continuing the story that uh to the
degree that the female Hemi clear series
are there at all it's just to help the
males feel better about themselves right
and only the toxic male snakes are
saying that the the male snakes are
presumably also possessed of the idea
that each individual is the best one
that their female snake has ever had
that's right and obviously this
conversation is making our female
Labrador really unhappy I think she just
has to sneeze
that's pretty much what I got all right
well
um
all right I tell you what I will wrap up
with a vignette that I think uh you this
is not I just got back last night so um
and you left literally the day that I
got back from Mexico so we've basically
not seen each other since the last live
stream I left as soon as the last live
stream ended and here we are yeah all
right so I got to Florida as you know
um Fort Lauderdale where the airport is
is not close to uh to West Palm Beach
where the
um where the DeSantis panel was and
um this was all on very short notice so
I decided to rent a car
and you know that time that that moment
when you've rented a car at the counter
and then they take you out and you go
into the parking lot and they say you
could have anything in this road right
and so
I got like oh she thinks I got to my row
and it was like
not impressive right there was like a
tricycle and there was a scooter with a
trash bag that you could wear to keep
the rain off and you know not not great
stuff but yeah there was also
inexplicably to me a convertible Mustang
[Laughter]
it's like they're all kind of already
convertibles with the top down
inherently but anyway so I looked at the
woman who had taken me out there like
that one is obviously in the wrong room
she's like no no you can have that one I
thought oh no okay but then I had this
argument with myself about so you're
gonna show up to the governor's thing in
a convertible Mustang like that sends a
kind of a weird non-academic message
right but then I you know I realized I
really just did not want to touch any of
these other you know vehicles that sort
of like vaccines so there's vehicles
that I might have got so I was like okay
oh I'll do it right yeah and I got the
thing and it was kind of crazy and uh
but it didn't leak it didn't have some
obvious like it had a transmission well
let's put it this way the rear windows
once opened did not fully close Okay
okay but that was the extent of the
leaking okay and other than that it was
you know it was kind of interesting and
you weren't held responsible for the
fact that you returned the car soaking
wetness No in fact when I did return the
car the guy told me that uh Ford had
just elected never to solve that problem
it was well known and that you had to
physically pull the windows up um so
anyway okay Ford I don't know what
you're up to but so I rented the car
and I did show up to the governor's
thing in the uh in the convertible
Mustang but nobody saw and then later we
uh some of us who were on the panel had
gone out to a meal and uh I offered to
drive Jay bhattacharya back to his hotel
of course and then I realized had not
rented a right time not done that and I
had this moment like you know I'm not a
very insecure person but I had this
moment of insecurity like oh my God Jay
bhattachary is a bet and so I started
making excuses and telling him I'd
rented this car and it was the only one
that was tolerable and all of this stuff
and uh
anyway Jay gets to the car and he's like
oh my God my 16 year old self would have
loved this car and so then you know Jay
bottatory and I uh tooled around on the
way to his hotel in a convertible
Mustang in uh West Palm Beach so anyway
that's a vignette for you nice oh it's
excellent yeah that's excellent
all right well uh we'll be back in six
we'll be back in 15 minutes but you'll
also be back uh for those of you who've
had enough of us for now in six days we
will be live streaming on December 23rd
Friday December 23rd at the usual time
uh noon 30 Pacific
but until then we also have our patreon
our private q a tomorrow so join us
there and come come find me at at my
patreon and we will be doing a live q a
tomorrow
um 11 A.M to 1 p.m with questions that
are awesome and a group that's really
great as well
um but we'll be back shortly with a
different q a you can ask questions at
darkhorsemmissions.com
um any logistical questions that you
have to be sent to darkforce moderator
gmail.com
and there's lots of other true stuff to
say but until next time you go to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone